[音楽]
初めまして赤のですまずですね皆さんは自分が想像をしていなかった人生を送るように
なったという経験ってありますかね
まあそれっていいいい魚は類にもあると思うんですけど僕はあります自分自身ではまあ
いい意味かなって思ってるんですけども
僕は今イスラムにあるテルアビブ大学というところで
電気電子工学を勉強しながら
その方はな
ヘルスケア medical technology の領域で日本とイスラエルを
つなぐ授業をする会社を起業していたりとかですね
原っで日本人に向けて
ゲストハウス運営していたらまあいろんなことしてるんですけど1年前は僕はこんな
ことしてるだなんて夢にも思っています
さんでした
まあ
皆さんイスラエルと聞いて
どんなイメージを思い浮かべますかねちょっと考えてみてください
おそらく
こういった紛争とか
収去
っていうものがまずパッと出てくるんじゃないかなと思うんですけど
日本でまあこれは事実ですけど日本ではあまり知られていない1年一面もありまして
それって
中東のシリコンバレーと言われているほどの技術開発だとか
スタートアップが盛んな国でもあるんですね
そのバックグラウンドを聞いたうえでああだからあいつはイスラエルに行きあったんか
とはならないと思うのでマフなぜイスラエルに行くようになったのかということを
今日はちょっとお話しさせていただこうと思います
僕はですね2年半前までここ大阪大学の
し悪夢の生徒でした
そして2015年4月16日
まさにこの会場のあの辺の席で
大会主催の留学セミナーを受けてたんですね
そのとき僕は自分を変えたいなって思ってたんです
振り返ってみると
高校の頃はバンドか部活とか
学校行事とかまあそういったことにまあ熱を入れるですねまずげなことばっかりしてた
んですよ
そして誤審の選択する時まあ真面目にちょっと考えてなかったんですね
ねまぁ父親が敗者のものですからその仕事を見てみるのがいいかなということで
大阪大学歯学部に進学しましたなぜかちょっとテンションが低いんですけど
うん8神具しませんまあこれはもっさもさですね
受験後のっっところで
で股生きようよとね呼称につい口わけですよねえ
よくわからない知覧人たちと座って
オリエンテーション一教授が彼らがあった入ってきて広告等にいうわけなんですね
皆さん入学おめでとう
これから皆さんは6年間勉強して
立派な歯医者さんになるんやねって言い合ったんですねそのとき僕はよっしゃー立派な
配送になったろう
と思えなかったんですね残念ながら
その時に
[音楽]
なぜ
あのそんなむしろ歯医者なるんやな買えないときっともうとなって思ってしまったん
ですね
そんなことを考えたわかるじゃないですが歯学部行ったらあいつのなるなんて
まぁ今日はそんなこともちゃんと耳が臭いまま入ってしまったんですね目村から初めて
自分というものにちゃんと向き合ってみたんですねそしたら
何かこう何もしてないのに
うんこすごいにちょっと影響を与えてみたいな
そんな風に思っている自分が見えてそれがすごい嫌いで気合で
どうにか変えたいなぁと思ってみたんですね
[音楽]
でまずお前がやりたいことはないねん
まず行動せよと思ったんですけど
それを声かけたところで何がしたいかわかんないんですよね
だって考えてみてください高校の時に朝起きてパン食いながらですよ
学校行って米事業を受けて編んで部活して塾行って授業を受けて自習室行って家帰って
ご飯食べて
次の日もそれの繰り返し
同じサイクルをずっと続けて
同じコミュニティの中でずっと過ごしていた人に対して
じゃああなたのやりたいことは何なんですか言われたときに
野鳥わかんないっすってなるじゃないですかで僕もその中の一人だったんですね
でその時考えてみると僕はこの社会にどういう人が入ってどういう職業が入ったって
どういう課題があるのかっていうことを全然死なんなあと思いました目はシンプルに
そういう社会のこと知りたいなーっていう好奇心みたいなものがそこになってようやく
は行ってきました
ん
とりあえず島今僕は空っぽです
まぁそれはいい今まで何もしてこなかったかなそれは認めますと
仕方ないけど
こっからどういう風に自分を自分に水を注いでいっぱいに中身のある人間していったら
いいかなっていうふうなことをそこから考えるになりました
ねちょっと鬱自分の人生が変わり始めたなって思います
それからというものをとにかくいろんなことしましたいろんなとこ行って色んな人だと
いうようなことしました
それで何をしたかっていうことはどうでもいいんですけど
まぁそこで気付いた一番大きいのはありきたりなんですけど胃の中の風な自分店って
思ったんですね
だが最もまあそういうことを繰り返していくうちにもう自分があったことないような人
だったりとか
今まで当たり前だと思ってたことがひっくり返されたりとかよくあってもっとそういう
体験をしたいなもっと世界史
みたいなってなってで世界を見てみたいって思ったんですね
海外に行ってみたいそういうふうに思いあげました
で次どうしようかなって考えていた時にある言葉飛びました
イスラエルで技術体力国らしいよ
をそうでかーって感じじゃないですか
僕はまじかこれにすごく惹かれたんですね
[音楽]
まあやっぱり皆さん先ほどシェアしたようにスイーツそういうイメージないじゃない
ですか
かつ僕の周りでイスラエルに入ってますみたいな日本人も誰もいなかったのでこれは
ちょっとおもろいぞとなったんですよね自分の中でこの行ってみようとなってなんだ
けど
イスネールに知り合いなんてまあいないんじゃないですか
なので知ってそうな人にとりあえず好アプローチしていって働けるとかないですか
生かしてくれません
うかなっていうことをとにかくお願いして言ったら
なんと向こうのスタートアップの方と面接とかをセットアップしてくれて最終的には
こんな感じでイスラエル人
6人に囲まれて a
今スタートアップで2ヶ月間インターンしてました
これだけ見たらお前これ六本木で写真撮ったんちゃうかって思う方がいるかもしれない
んですけどちゃんと椅子で撮ってます
で
a
ここをねえ2カ月過ごしているうちに
ある過去を思い出したんですね
僕は入隊に敵国繰り返してでで過去に手術も4回しています
そのときに全部カテーテルという細い管を使って行うまあ手術していただいたんです
けど
はいとか心臓いじってにもかかわらず傷がほとんど残ってない
これって凄いことじゃないですか
それに教育してあ
そういう技術に助けないと僕もそういうものに興味があるやってみたいなって思ったん
ですね
でイスラエルってどうなのかって聞いたなぁ
あの医療探検に噛んでいる方はちょっとご存知かもしれないんですけど
あの
メイドイースナイルの医療器で結構 ct ところであるんですね
で実際データ見てみたら1人人口1人当たりの医療機器突極数が世界一だったりとか
先程言ったスタートアップの全体のうちの16%が
ライフサイエンスまあいわゆる子健康とたいい関わるものに取り組んでいる子が多く
なってるっていうところがあってまあ結構でかい市場なんですね
そこで自分の興味とこういう環境が整っているとでかつ
イスラエルかける医療で何かしてる日本人ってまあいなかったんですよ
でその現場を見た時に僕は
思いました
俺や雪崩やん年譜
もそう思った時から
イスマイルに行きたい残りたい自然に思うようになりました
ねえ最終的にまぁ w 大学に編入してま残ることになったんですけど実際渡りますで
なった時に僕は一つ目標を立てました
それが
イスラエルのヘルスケアといえば赤のという存在になるということです
これ普通に買えた無理じゃないですかそれまで2ヶ月しかイスラエルにいてない
しかも別にメディカルのプロフェッションでもない自分が
そんな人間になれるのかなってすごい不安だったんですけどまぁ前年をない
コースを取ってしまったのでそこまでやり抜きたいな覚悟で臨みました
そっからというものをまずはブログで情報発信し始めました
これ今でも海外スタートアップバグまとめとか調べたら google 1も出てくる
んですけど
まあそういう感じ好評なったのでそれから独自でサイトを作って
isoya のヘルスケアとか medical technology に特化した
情報を発信し始めました
そのようにして取材とかまあリサーチとかを重ねて行くうちに
めずら犬のヘルスケア community 最後のコミュニティのパウダーの方と
仲良くなって
明日から始まるイスラエルデリゲーションとかもサポートするようになったりとか
愛知年前は全然素人だって僕がこういった
事業だとかへ
こういう講演活動につながるようになりました
確かに僕はすごく遠回り
回り道をしたかもしれません
けど僕はそれに対して一切の後悔してません
僕は
過去に経験した大剣とか出会ってきた人とか
失敗とかあって全て繋がっていると思っててん
あの時のあの言葉がなかったらいっすが位にも入ってないし
僕は東京で行った時にシェアハウスにそんなしてもらってたんですけどその経験が
なかったら今1歳でゲストハウスなんかしてないですし
もちろん健康第一ですけど手術もしなかった医療機器なんで今日ももたなかったでしょ
だから皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
あえて
普段やらないようなことをこれを持ちっぽ思い切ってやってみたらどうですか
はじめはちょっと気持ち悪いかもしれません例えば小さなことでもいい
家に帰る時にいつもと違う3ちょっとっ
もしくは今伝わっている日隣の人に話しかけてみましょ
その選択が
いつ何が起こるか分からない未来に大きなきっかけを与えてくれる
その可能性があるかもしれません
なぜ僕はこのような話をしたかっていうと
こういうイスラエルでいろいろやっていることに至ったのも
大学1年生の時に感じては悶々とした気持ちがスタートだということです
なんで自分は
もう熱意を持ってこれやりたいという者が無いんやとか
やりたいものがない自分なんてダメな奴なんだって思う方もしかしたら僕みたいにいる
かもしれません
けど僕はそのあなたが駄目な奴なんじゃなくて
[音楽]
だなぁ自分の中の選択肢が少ないのとか知らないだけなんじゃないかなと思います
自分が知らないことを悩んでも
時間の無駄だと思います自分が想像できないことだからです
ってから僕はまず知ることで自分にとって大切なことそしてそういうの紐を判断できる
んじゃないかそう思います
ので選択肢を増やせる環境へ飛び込んでみるということで皆さんが想像もしていなかっ
たようなきっかけや出会いが
つかむをつかめるかいやそこにはある
これが僕が2年間回り道をして今日みなさんにお伝えしたかったことですありがとう
ございました
[拍手]